[Music]
let's go out to Missouri and talk to the
great and wonderful Logan what up Logan
how we doing how's it going John good
sorry you had to hear that weird thing
from
Nathan it's all good I'm I can double
down on the Mexican though ex yes yes
glad I'm glad you didn't say you want to
eat penguin all right so what's up man
uh so um it's been it's been a rough
month man
um what happened uh well my wife she
decided that our marriage was over and I
didn't get a confrontation I didn't get
a conversation I didn't get nothing so
uh my question to you sir is how do you
move forward when you know that you are
never going to get the closure that you
need to get past
something like
[Music]
that I think there's a couple of layers
in between now and
closure um no I understand that I
understand it's going to be a process
and everything I'm just I'm very
self-aware and very you know conscious
of the process of healing from emotional
trauma and grief but it's just this this
is a situation that I've never been
faced with in my life and I I was never
prepared for why'd she leave
man she's just she said that she hasn't
been happy for a while um we we haven't
had a proper face-to-face conversation
or anything about this I'm an over the
road trucker and she told me that she
was going down to see some family for a
couple of days I got back from a run she
left when I left to you know get on the
road again she was coming back up and
then I found out all the stuff that
happened dude why aren't you on her
front porch right now wherever she
is uh because if I do I'm
probably going to get arrested not
because I'm going to do anything violent
but because the Dude thinks I'm
psychotic oh she had another guy's house
yeah she's already with another dude she
went down to go see some family but
during that time she was not seeing
family she was moving stuff in with this
dude that she just met down there which
I don't even know if it's you know is
it's a big mess and she didn't just meet
him dude I know I know
yeah it it's clearly been happening for
a while apparently the conversation that
I've heard is because this dude's ex
contacted my mom and started asking
questions and like it got it got all
kind of Twisted but that's how I found
out like this dude his ex contacted my
mom my mom contacted me like hey
something's going down I just feel like
there's a group of people in the
background going Jerry Jerry just
chanting I know right I know all right
so if she if she got in a car if she
knocked on on the door or you're sitting
there watching TV tonight and she walked
in the front door are you having her
back or is your marriage
over I
mean answer just straight answer as
straight as you can answer all right as
straight as it can be yeah 99.9% no
no your marriage is
over like yeah like okay because some of
the things that have been said yeah
can't be taken back and they cannot be
taken lightly well lying to you and
moving out and moving in with some other
guy and sleeping with him for the last
how month that shouldn't be lightly
either no yeah I I but the thing is like
I we when I was out on a run when all of
this went down m mhm I was on my way
back and she called me and said okay do
you want to fix this do you want to work
on this and I said yes and I expected
her to be there when I got back and she
was
gone so did y'all have a big blow up
that she finally just said enough's
enough there there was no big blow up I
didn't even know she was unhappy like
for the last year and a half it's been
rough because that's how long I've been
driving truck for okay and I always
tried to get her to come on the road
with me I always tried to get her to you
know do things with me when I was home
but she always prioritized her friends
and she always had some reason not to
come on the road with me so she's been
out of this marriage for a long time I
know that now I didn't realize it at the
time sure and so one of the scariest
things about finding out your spouse has
cheated on
you one is that picture you have in your
head of her having sex with somebody
else right there's that very visceral
reality right and that was eating me up
for like is the first two weeks of all
of this and now it's like I've just for
some reason the last week or so I've
been able to push that out of my head
I've just not been able to think about
that fantastic yes yes and and I want to
tell you something thinking about that
over time is a choice you can't help the
lightning bolt the image that just
shoots in your head you can choose to
hit play on that videotape that's
looping in your head okay okay that's
number one and most people think that um
finding out your spouse your girlfriend
your boyfriend is cheating on you that
that is the worst part it's
not the worst part is realizing what
you're realizing in slow motion right
now and you no longer trust
Logan yeah because you missed it yeah
for two years your wife's been out of
this thing and you didn't know and you
were busting your butt to get certified
you've been busting your butt to give
her a better life by driving right yeah
and you picture over the last few weeks
that it has felt like a very one-sided
marriage for a lot longer than I
realized that's right I was putting in
all of this work and all this effort to
keep providing and making sure that she
didn't have to do things she didn't want
to do I've paid for cruises I've paid
for trips I've paid for girls trips and
I'm just like okay but when am I going
to get those things and it never came
yeah and
so you find yourself on really un like
kind of you're out on a lake that's
Frozen and all the ice is cracking
around you yeah right and that's a scary
feeling not being able to trust your own
gut and your own
intuition so there's a couple of things
that are important number one uh my
friend Dave says this and I love it when
somebody leaves you when your marriage
is over
the relationship has ended the Romantic
relationship has ended the Friendship at
the time has ended I think friendships
can happen down the road um when things
are trust reestablished and this isn't
every group I know there's people who
consciously uncouple and they hold hands
down to the courthouse to get divorced
and that's a whole other
conversation but this is now a business
transaction my dad has been saying that
for so long it's a business transaction
is she in your car
uh no not anymore um actually she was in
my vehicle she's she was driving my car
for like three years and she used my car
that I came into this marriage with to
go and do all of this stuff and then
just last week we managed to or my
lawyer convinced her to come up and swap
her out of my vehicle into another
vehicle that we had that we both on the
time for and she was never on the title
for my car so I'm glad I got that so
this is now a business transaction she's
made a grown-up choice and with that
grownup choice is going to come a lot of
grown-up consequences
okay it's also going to cost you some
it's going to suck it's gonna be
hard I want you to stop texting
her I haven't she she cut off her phone
she disconnected her phone and
everything okay I have no contact okay I
want you to let your attorney do his job
or her job
okay and then the second thing is is
good oldfashioned
grief and you cannot do this by
yourself I have a fantastic support
structure good like those first two days
when I found out everything and you know
all the thoughts were running through my
head if I didn't have my family I don't
think I could have been doing my job and
functioning as a person at all yeah I'm
Amazed you're even still standing
upright but here's what that looks like
that looks like you getting two or three
people and you all go to dinner when are
you doing local or are you doing week
long runs about week long runs I'm on a
run to Oregon now okay so when you get
done from a run how long are you at home
before you turn on and go back out uh
two to three days sometimes four you
have to prioritize those two to three
days you got to get your laundry done
you got to go to the bank you gotta get
a haircut you gotta do that stuff but
also you got to have a dinner or a
breakfast with the guys
yep and you have to have the courage all
those thoughts you're having when you're
out on the road all the anger all the
frustration all the tears all the
singing all the yelling you have to have
the courage to write that stuff down or
if you want to be safer D speak it into
a like a phone app while you're driving
you have to have the courage to sit down
and tell those guys out loud what you're
going through in real
time yeah if if I if I didn't have the
people that I have I would would have
fallen apart I know Hey listen you're
going to fall apart be more great I
can't be not I cannot be more grateful
for the people that I have around me um
goodly this best friends well I I want
you not to just talk to him on the phone
and not just text them I want you to sit
in FA face to face with them if you can
and yeah this
imaginary you have fantasized already
about a couple of things finding this
guy in a dark alley and doing your worst
you have
actually it never crossed my mind
because I never blamed the guy oh it's
crossing my mind for you he's not the
one who did this this was her decision
completely I mean he's with a married
woman but but I get I get your sent I I
agree I I agree with that sentiment and
I I completely understand where you're
coming from but he made this Choice well
that's a
very that's very wise of you good for
you it's very mature of you you're more
mature than I would be being but the
second thing is there is not going to to
be some magic
um if you had 30 minutes with her just
to just to say everything you needed to
say you wouldn't feel better when it was
over on this side of it you think you
would you
wouldn't there's no magic cathar
catharsis this this
ah it won't
exist it won't
exist
and so the hardest thing you have to do
is let go of the fantasy that if you
just had a conversation if you just knew
why if you just fill in the blank that
all this would feel different and I
think at this point it wouldn't what
with what's happened has
happened it's just
heartbreaking and I want you to not do
anything drastic or anything wild for 6
months I want you to keep meeting with
your buddies once a week and your family
whoever it is that's your support
network I want you all to meet in person
I want you to talk about what you're
struggling
with and my guess is if you've lived in
a marriage where you've been trying and
trying and trying and trying and there's
all this deception going on underneath
the underneath the water um you're going
to find strange pockets of Peace too the
sun's going to come out in places that
you didn't know the sun had gone down
and I want you to lean into
that and I want you to make sure you
take care of your body EX exercise want
you to eat as clean as you can even
though you're on the road I know it's
very very hard want you to be
intentional want you to sleep when you
can I've see guys out at some on some of
the side trucks they've got kettle bells
on the side of their with with they're
out there doing their workouts with
their kettle bells outside their their
rigs I want that to be you I want you to
take care of
yourself I want you to look up in six
months and I don't want you to have
bought a bunch of stupid crap I want you
to be in relatively good health I want
this divorce I want your attorney to
have been doing their job and kicking
butt for
you I don't want you to be in a season
of grief heartbreak maybe take a journal
with you and write down at night when
you're sleeping in the back of your rig
write down how you feel which sounds so
cheesy and lame I know I know I know
write that stuff
down then it's 7 months 8 months 9
months once you start coming up from Air
I want you to give me a call back then
there's not a thing that you can do
right now that's just going to snap your
fingers you're caught in a in a river
that's running fast and you're going to
hang on to your buddies and you're going
to ride this one
out and I want you to be healthy and
smart as you do it and I'm so so sorry
for you I'm glad that you're not talking
to her I'm glad you're not communicating
with her I don't want you talking to her
friends or this guy's ex just get out of
the drama get out of the drama and in
these kind of situations there's a high
rate that she calls you at some point
can we talk no no you talk to my
attorney you made your grown-up decision
and now you're going to have to live
with the grown-up
consequences and I'm heartbroken for you
brother I really
am man I'm heartbroken for
you